με λόγο του κορονόγιπιστεε ότι είμαστε πιο έτοιμη μετά από αυτή την πανδιμίαν αυτό που
συντοποιήσαμε ναι ότι καπία χώρα δεν εδαν προεϊτιμασμένοι κανένας συστημα γίας δεν ήταν προιτιμασμένο αλλά
για να μπορείς να έχεις ανθε να ανθεκτικό συστημαγίες πρέπει να έχεις πραγματικά να κάνεις
αλλαγές και γι αυτό βάλαμε τις βάσεις για μια ευρωπαϊκία ενοσηγίας για τους ευρωπέίους πολιτες
ενισχίοντας όλα τα θέματα που αφορούν την ασφάλεια στες κρίσεις δημόσιας οιγείες τις ευρωπαϊκής αένωσης
πιστεύω ότι είμαστε πολύ πιο έτοιμοι σίγουρα ακόμη περιπρέπει να γίνουν αρκετά αλλά αλλάξαμε και
τον τρόπο που προσυγκίζουμε τα θέματα ηγείας και αυτό το βλέπουμε και άλλες κρίσεις που
είχαμε παραδείγματος χαριόταν ήταν οι κρίσι με την επιδημία τις ευλογιάς των πιθήκων το είκο
ικοσιδύο αμέσως επικοινωνήσαν οι υπουργή γείας μαζί μου και ζητήσαν μπορείτε να κοινηθείτε συσκεντρικά να
μας προμηθεύσετε εμβόλεια αυτό θε ήτα νάδι ανόητον πριν εξι χρόνια και μέσα σε τρεις
εβδομάδες μια καινούρια αρχή που έχουμε δημιουργήσει για ια αρχιετιμότητας και άμεσης ανταπόκρισης μπόρεσε να
δώσει στα κράτη μέλι που είχαν πρόβλημε εμβόλεια ιαυτό πστεποτι αλλάξαντα πράγματα στην στην ιγεία
ποιαι ποια είναι πολιτική πρωτεραιότητα για τα κράτημέλι θεμίτε ότι κάποιοι τύπησαν της τέλλαν κυριακή
δου χωρίζε λόγο ιδικά την περίοδα της πανδιμίας ακουστικάν διάφορα ήταν κυπερίοδος τέτοια θείτε τι
κάποιοι σα σε χτύπησαν σεσαγωγικά άδεικα μπρίσκεσε σε μια θέση όπως σε μια οπλιοδήποτε πολιτική
θέση αναμένεις να υπάρχουν και οι κριτικοί και κποτε άδικ